[Musique]
c'est ici dans cet immense site
d'enfouissement à sainte-sophie dans les
laurentides que se retrouve 17 % de tous
les déchets du québec
chaque jour de 200 à 400 camions
viennent y déverser leur cargaison
ils proviennent de la région mais aussi
de l'outaouais de lanaudière et du grand
montréal la partie exploitée du site
déjà grande comme 285 terrain de
football américain est presque rempli
québec vient d'autoriser son expansion
l'entreprise wealth management pourra
donc continuer d'y enfouir des déchets
sur une surface équivalente à 100 autres
terrains de football ce convoi qui est
excavées c'est la dernière cellule de la
zone 5 b qui nous amènera jusqu'à la fin
de 2022 par la suite il va y avoir des
boisements graduelle
on aménage une cellule par année
jusqu'en 2039 de la cara dont moins de
20 ans 18 millions de tonnes de déchets
supplémentaires auront donc été enfouis
6 et le site de sainte sophie
or alors atteint sa pleine capacité
comme celui d'ailleurs de lachenaie le
plus gros de la province qui reçoit 40 %
des déchets du grand montréal
là on est un petit peu acculé au pied du
mur parce que je savais on n'a pas une
bonne planification à long terme sur
l'île nation des déchets au québec on
gère toujours en silo 7 dont les années
60 le québec comptait pourtant un
millier de sites d'enfouissement mais au
fil des ans avec des normes
environnementales plus sévères
leur gestion est devenue coûteuse et la
très grande majorité ont été abandonnées
comme plusieurs municipalités ont cessé
d'avoir la propre dépotoir au fil des
ans elles ont envoyé leurs poubelles
leurs matières résiduelles via vers des
plus gros sites d'enfouissement donc
c'est pas car et a manqué aujourd'hui
convoi des camions de vidange faire des
2 300 kilomètres pour aller porter leurs
cargaisons si on veut pas dire rostov
pas aujourd'hui la province compte 38
sites d'enfouissement dont cinq immenses
qui gèrent 80 % de nos déchets
actuellement au québec on est presque en
point de rupture avec les quantités
qu'ils sont disposés et les capacités
et existants il faut donc agir vite pour
éviter une crise des déchets pour de bon
vers quoi on s'en va ou moins pour les
20 prochaines années
joseph zayed préside la commission du
bape qui proposera d'ici la fin de
l'année des orientations gouvernement il
y a plusieurs lieux d'enfouissement qui
vont devoir fermer parce que il n'ya des
lieux potentiels qui peuvent être
ouverts ou est-ce qu ici se tirer
qu'est-ce que ça impliquerait et qu'est
ce que la population soit rares sont
ceux en tout cas qui souhaitent avoir un
site d'enfouissement dans leur
municipalité autour de sainte sophie
il y a les résidents pour qui la
cohabitation se passe bien non ce
concours avait de ça je trouve car m'a
donné il faudrait faire autre chose que
d'enfouir des déchets mais je me dis que
ce soit 5,6 ou une autre ville à quelque
part en faut bien qu'ils mettaient
quelque part personnellement je sens
pauvre fait que honnêtement tête à par
la chaleur l'achalandage au niveau des
dix véhicules et il y a les opposants
comme normand léo beaudet qui nous a
rencontrés sur la route 158 à saint
jérôme c'est un des endroits les plus
fréquentés
s'ils ont pesé de la route des vidanges
qu'on a appelé sa coalition espère
encore faire annuler l'expansion du site
c'est pas plus de deux parties un petit
dépotoir loin moins lourdes et patronne
à laval et à montréal et ya des endroits
qui répondent mieux qu'ici qui va en
falloir d'autres sept lots mais j'ai
hâte de voir qui va accepter la mairesse
de sainte sophie vente waste management
un bon citoyen corporatif dit elle on
n'a pas demandé ni d'odeur ni camionnage
ni de désagrément ils font les bonnes
façons l'enfouissement
mais si on veut arrêter ça s'apprend à
récupération et compostage tous le
disent récupérer et composter davantage
atténuera les problèmes il y a bien eu
quelques progrès au cours des années
mais aussi de sainte-sophie on ne les
voit pas on va et spots être d'environ
un pour cent par année avec une
croissance démographique qui en demande
d'un pour ça on vient ici n
les les efforts selon recyc-québec 5
millions 588 milles tonnes de déchets
ont été éliminés au québec en 2019 soit
la plus grande quantité en dix ans la
bonne nouvelle c'est que les efforts
citoyens paraissent les ordures
ménagères ont diminué de 39% de 2009 à
sauf qu'au même moment les déchets
provenant des commerces des institutions
et industries eux ont augmenté de 35%
karel ménard demande qu'on taxe les
entreprises qui n'en font pas assez
6 mois en entreprise privée je mets
produits sur le marché qui ne sera pas
au risque les en bout de ligne je vais
être pénalisés donc je vais m'assurer
que ce que jouer sur le marché va être
accepté par les centres de tri et votre
ultime en être recyclés donc ça va me
responsabiliser une chose est certaine
dans quelques années nous serons encore
brille avec des résidus qu'il faudra
éliminer et les quantités seront
colossales encore si on regarde
l'exemple de toronto il ya 3 millions de
tonnes par annick sont acheminés au
michigan faute d'avoir développé des
solutions locales
alors je pense faudrait éviter le piège
de la pensée magique ans par saclay
matière vont disparaître de nouveau site
d'enfouissement devront sans doute voir
le jour au québec notamment dans le
grand montréal
mais il faudra accepter de passer d'une
idée du pas dans ma cour à celle du
chacun dans sa cour